Now as a daily practice, some like to start with a little ritual, bowing, lighting a candle and incense, and taking the refuges and training rules.
Although this is not necessary, some small ceremony can set the tone.
I have recorded the chant for bowing, taking the three refuges, in the Buddha Dhamma Sangha, and also the five training rules, should you want to take them before a sitting.
There is also at the end a final bow.
This is how to pronounce the Pali, the language of the scriptures.
When bowing, The end of the word is like our Ang in I rang the bell.
It means I bow to the Buddha, the Dharma and the Sangha.
Boddhang Saranang Gacchami Dhammang Saranang Gacchami Sanggang Saranang Gacchami Duthi Ampi Boddhang Saranang Gacchami Duthi Ampi Dhammang Saranang Gacchami Duthi Ampi Sanggang Saranang Gacchami
I take refuge in the Buddha, the Dhamma and the Sangha.
For the second time, I take refuge in the Buddha, Dhamma, Sangha.
And for the third time, I take refuge in the Buddha, Dhamma and Sangha.
The five training rules or precepts are pronounced like this.
PANATI PATA VERAMANI SIKAPADANG SAMADI YAMI ADINADHANA VERAMANI SIKAPADANG SAMADI YAMI KAMESUMI CHACARA VERAMANI SIKAPADANG SAMADI YAMI
And they are translated like this.
Not to harm any living beings, not to take what is not freely given, not to abuse our sexual powers,
not to use wrong speech, not to take any drugs or drinks that tend to cloud the mind.
At the end of the session, it is customary to complete it with another three bows.
imāyā dhamānū dhammapattipatiya buddhāṃ puje mi dhammāṃ puje mi saṅgāṃ puje mi
by following the path of the Dharma, the true law, I bow to the Buddha, the Dharma and the Sangha.
And finally, before you rise, make a determination to devote this day, just this one day, to mindfulness with a caring heart.